[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about how
to use the singular value decomposition
to build linear regression models from
data okay so if we have data for a
number of input variables and we want to
build a model for some outcome
prediction some prediction of some other
variable we care about then we can
essentially build a linear regression
model ax equals to B well we're
essentially trying to solve for the
slope of the relationship X from
measurement data so this is an example I
like walking through this is the Boston
housing market data this is a built in
data set in MATLAB and this has
essentially been converted into a data
file that you can read into Python okay
so you load housing data again all of
the code and data are in zip files in
this data book you dub calm website and
the Boston housing data is pretty
interesting so what you essentially have
our home prices in this B vector in
Boston and then a number of measurements
of features of that home things like you
know maybe how many bedrooms or what
neighborhood is it in is it close to a
freeway is it close to an elementary
school how densely is it populated you
know people per kilometer or something
like that
okay per square kilometer and so there's
a number of input factors I think
there's 13 of them so there are 13 input
factors in this matrix a 13 columns and
something like 500 506 houses where we
have the price and so what we're trying
to build is a little model for X we want
to solve for X to best fit to best
predict the housing price based on those
13 factors neighborhood density number
of bedrooms things like that okay and so
we have data for a we have data for B
for those 500 houses and we're trying to
build this little Model X so that if
there was a new house I could predict
much it would sell for just based on
those 13 factors you know what
neighborhood how close to a school how
many bedrooms things like that okay
pretty simple idea it's a linear
regression model based on data so we're
going to load this data and I'm also
gonna pad the data with a column of ones
because remember when we do this linear
regression for these input factors A to
B essentially our linear regression
model is going to go through the origin
unless I give it the the possibility of
having a y-intercept and so what I'm
actually gonna do is I'm going to tack
on a column of ones here so that I can
also have a factor that just tells me
what is kind of the mean value of the
house so that's going to allow me to
build a model that is not doesn't go
through the origin but is lifted off a
little bit okay so that's what what
we're doing here is we're padding with
ones so we can have a non zero offset
and again solving for this best fit X is
super simple you just solve for it using
pseudo inverse so the best fit X is
given by a dagger times B where a dagger
is the pseudo inverse which is the Sigma
inverse u transpose times B okay so
that's super easy to compute and that's
being computed right here we compute the
SVD of a and then we build this X tilde
this best-fit X here and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to plot the
original house price for the 506 houses
and the predicted house price in
different colors so let's show that here
good and so you see in white here is the
true House value this is in thousands of
dollars on the y axis and what I've also
done is sorted those homes so they came
in kind of this random order next what
I'm going to do is I'm going to sort
those homes from cheapest to most
expensive on the true housing value so
that you can see what the trends are
okay now of course you can tell that
this is from a long time
because you can't buy a house in Boston
for $40,000 anymore but this housing
data you see that the blue curve which
is our regression model our little 13
factor model actually does a really good
job of capturing the general trends in
the true housing data and although there
is some statistical fluctuation you can
see like you know there is a house to
house variability here you get the
general trend from from low-cost to
high-cost houses
based on these 13 factors now I guess we
should probably plot the significance of
the different attributes so let's do
that here so one thing you can do that's
kind of neat is you can actually make a
bar plot of the magnitudes of these X
that the Model X that you have here and
that's what we're seeing here and you
can actually see kind of the
significance of each of these factors in
driving the prediction of the home value
so I don't know exactly what these
attributes are but attribute 10 is
really really important and it
positively correlates with home value so
if you if you have more a factor 10
maybe that's proximity to a good
elementary school or a good school
district you're gonna have a higher home
value seven and eight are also highly
correlated but they're anti correlated
with high home value so they're
important factors but the more of seven
and eight you have the lower the home
value you're gonna have okay so seven
and eight and ten are really important
and based on the sign you can tell if
they drive kind of a positive or a
negative trend in home value okay that's
kind of neat so I want to point out that
what I did here by essentially taking
the entire data set all 506 houses and
using them to train a regression model
and then plot how the regression model
does on that training data that's
completely cheating so in in kind of
modern learning and statistical analysis
and machine learning it's completely
considered cheating to take the whole
data set build a model and then see how
good you did on that training set
because you could over fit the model to
that date
so instead what you want to do in
general is you want to chop your data up
into a portion that you're going to use
to Train and a portion that you're going
to use to test and you want to train the
model on one portion and test it on a
completely different portion that you
didn't use at all to train the Model X
okay that's how you validate your model
okay and so I'm going to show you what
that looks like here where we're loading
the exact same data we're doing the
exact same thing except now I'm taking
the first half of my data the first 250
3 houses and I'm going to use those to
train a model and I'm gonna use the
second half to test the model so
nothing's changed except I'm only gonna
train the X model on the first half and
I'm gonna test it on the second half and
now what you can see this is my
prediction on the training set and again
you do a really really good job of
capturing the basic trends of the true
housing value based on the model makes
sense we built the model based on that
data but on the testing data you see
that there's actually there's some
region where you get the trends pretty
accurately
but over here you're not doing a very
good job of fitting fitting the housing
data the model is actually pretty poor
over here ok so this just goes to show
that the model I developed here might
not actually work that well in
generalizing to other other houses now
when I see a dataset like this there's a
few things I think of immediately the
first one is probably when this housing
data was collected it was collected
neighborhood by neighborhood and it
wasn't shuffled the order of these these
houses wasn't shuffled or mixed up so it
looks to me like this is maybe a
neighborhood maybe this is a
neighborhood and so on and so forth and
that's why we're doing so poorly on this
second half of the test data because
that's another neighborhood we've never
seen before and so we don't know kind of
how those factors drive home values in
that neighborhood we haven't seen before
ok and so a thing you can normally do
here that helps a lot
is you can you can essentially randomly
shuffle the order of these rows so that
I kind of get a random sample of all of
these neighborhoods and I use half of
those for my training data and half of
those for my testing data so instead of
just use naively using the first half in
the second half I'm kind of randomly
going to pull half for training and
randomly pull half for testing and we're
gonna see how that does so again in
Python this is pretty easy again nothing
has changed in the code except here I
have created this random permutation
vector P which basically just randomly
gets different indices from 1 to 506 and
so I'm going to reshuffle the rows of a
and I'm going to reshuffle the rows of B
but I'm gonna shuffle them in exactly
the same way and similarly I'm gonna
take the first half of that shuffled
matrix to train and the second half of
that shuffled matrix to test and when I
run this this is actually what I want to
see okay so I have this is my training
data and I actually have a pretty good
fit still of the individual fluctuations
of the training data but now I'm doing a
much much better job on my testing data
because I've done a better job of
statistically sampling my kind of
neighborhood space in my training data
and in my testing data so that gives me
more representative models X because I'm
doing a better job of sampling the
neighborhoods in my training data and so
that model generalizes better to my
testing data okay so this is just giving
you an idea of how you can build linear
regression models from data using the
SVD in Python okay thank you